well this was an investigation that
began five and a half years ago into uh
allegations of corruption involved in
the initial investigation uh into
Stephen Lawrence's murder in 1993. that
investigation didn't find any evidence
of corruption but as it went on it
Unearthed what its own investigators
thought pointed to misconduct in public
office by some of those detectives in
very senior roles right at the start
after Stephen's murder and essentially
they thought they had found breaches of
their duties in essence but in Broad
terms mistakes that were made that
rather scuppered that initial
investigation that led originally to no
charges so there were four officers two
superintendents who were essentially at
different times in charge of that first
investigation a chief superintendent and
detective Chief superintendent who
oversaw that first investigation and a
detective inspector and two and a half
years ago they were told that they faced
the possibility of the that criminal
charge of misconduct in a public office
now the crown prosecution service has
just made its decision we haven't heard
from the CPS officially but I know that
the three superintendent ranking
officers have been told they won't face
charges and I also understand that the
the lower ranking officer the detective
inspector he too has been told that he
won't face charges
now I don't think this is entirely
unexpected in the light of what the
commissioner of Scotland Yard so Mark
Rowley was saying yesterday he was
giving evidence to the police and crime
committee his political Masters if you
like and he talked about those early
mistakes he said they were grave they
may have ruined the case he said they
did irreparable damage evidence was lost
opportunities were missed and I think
listening to the commissioner yesterday
the way he was talking those remarks
would have been seen as very injudicious
if and I guess he knew this decision
yesterday if he thought that those
officers were going to face criminal
charges so I think that was a big clue
yesterday that these officers would be
told that that they weren't to be
prosecuted and you can only imagine the
relief that those officers must be
feeling today they've effectively been
under investigation yeah for what at
least two and a half years perhaps
longer they are all elderly men now they
are all retired long retired and it
would of course been a terrible end to
their career to have to face criminal
charges
um but they're not whether we're going
to hear from them at some stage today
it's not clear
and of course those mistakes that have
been well aired over many many years
were highlighted in the MacPherson
report into the original police
investigation and that too talked about
fundamental errors professional
incompetence institutional racism and
the failure of leadership nonetheless
those officers who were in charge of
that investigation aren't going to face
any prosecution